madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chez un collègue
vous voyez nous constatons que
ceux qui sont minoritaires aujourd'hui
utilisent finalement quelques
réglementations obstructives pour ne pas
admettre qu'ils sont minoritaires ici
dans l'hémicycle
et
je vous regarde chez un collègue vous
avez le sourire aux lèvres
vous êtes satisfaite vous réjouis
vous êtes contents d'avoir pu trouver
une petite messe quierie obstructive
pour ne pas laisser une niche aller
jusqu'au bout
tu vas la fermer
non c'est pas possible non monsieur
serveur c'est une invictive monsieur
Servan non chers collègues on peut pas
en venir aux affectifs de cette manière
là la séance est suspendue pour 5
minutes pas possible